هشام ماذا عن المكان الاكثر اكتظاظا في
غزه ا كيف يعيش الناس على وقع استمرار هذه
الحرب خصوصا مع استمرار انقطاع الاتصالات
على
القطاع احوال واوضاع صعبه لاسما في ظل
انقطاع الاتصالات لليوم الثامن على
التوالي وهذه المده هي المده الاطول منذ
100 يوم منذ بدات الحرب الاسرائيليه او
اكثر من 100 يوم هذه المده هي المده
الاطول وبالتالي اتصال الناس مع بعضهم
البعض عاد الى الطرق البدائيه من اجل
الوصول وهو الاهم من اجل الوصول الى
سيارات الاسعاف الى سيارات الدفاع المدني
تحتاج تحتاج هذه العائلات وهؤلاء السكان
الى الوصول الى اقرب نقطه الى اقرب مستشفى
ليبلغوا عن طبيعه الاهداف التي استهدفتها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه ومن ثم
تتحرك سيارات الاسعاف وسيارات الدفاع
المدني ولكن ان تتخيلي ان هذه المده من
الطريق من مكان القصف الى المستشفى ومن ثم
تتحرك سيارات الاسعاف هذه مده طويله
بالتاكيد تودي بحياه عشرات من الجرحى
الذين يكونون مصابين باصابات خطيره في هذه
المناطق المستهدفه لذلك فان الاوضاع تزداد
خطوره يوما بعد اخر في رفح في جنوب القطاع
الاوضاع خطيره للغايه ربما ليست على صعيد
القارات الاسرائيليه فهي ربما الاكثر
الاقل حده في رفح
ربما في هذا المكان الاكثر اكتظاظا في
السكان هناك حرب من نوع مختلفه هناك حرب
من اجل توفير ادنى مقومات الحياه في رفح
في رفح لا يوجد مياه صالحه للشرب كافيه
لكل هذا العدد الكبير من السكان نحن نتحدث
عن مليون و300 ال نسمه او ما يزيد بعد ان
كانت رفح فيها سكان 300000 نسمه اليوم هم
البنى التحتيه المياه الصالحه للشرب
مقومات الحياه المختلفه من مواد اساسيه
ودقيق وكل هذه الاحتياجات اليوميه التي
يحتاجها السكان هنا في رفح هم والنازحون
هي غير متوفره وبالتالي الاوضاع كارثيه
للغايه لا يوجد في رفع متر واحد فارغ لا
يوجد فيه نازحون لم تنصد فيه خيام الحدود
مع مصر كل هذه الحدود على طولها نحو ثلاث
13 م من البحر وحتى اقرب نقطه الى معبر
رفح لكن المناطق الشرقيه هي خطيره بسبب
استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي كلها نصبت فيها
خيام وبالتالي هذه الخيام تحتاج الى بنى
تحتيه تحتاج الى صرف صحي تحتاج الى مياه
تحتاج الى مياه صالحه للشرب وتحتاج الى
الغذاء والى الدواء وكل هذا غير متوفر
واذا تحدثنا عن الدواء فنحن نتحدث عن
كارثه صحيه وطبيه في ظل هذا النقص الحاد
في هذا الدواء هشام زقوت مراسل الجزيره
كنت معنا من رفح شكرا لك